hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we are joined on the couch today by a
very special guest we have Guy Williams
from what it affects here you are a
senior visual effects supervisor at the
company you've been there since Lord of
the Rings yeah I've been in this
industry for over 30 years now just the
the chance to come out and talk about
some of the crazy projects we've had a
chance to work on in the past hey you
know we're all about the poorest stretch
in here what we're going to be looking
at the most advanced
oh it's remarkable man if it doesn't
move exactly like you're used to seeing
then it just it'll wreck the entire shot
and we'll be looking at eagley from
Peacemaker that beautiful illegal boy
and the difference between hair and
Feathers it's complex we're also going
to be taking a look at She-Hulk and some
of the effects that went into that for
instance all the incredible detail that
goes into making eyeballs photorealistic
and emotionally realistic and we're
going to be looking at one of the most
insane wonders from Guardian of the
Galaxy 3.
oh wow 18 shots 16 stitches can you find
them all I bet you can't and that's more
stitches than I've had is it no no I
feel like you've definitely I've had
more stitches
[Music]
come on Drax seriously dude
guardians galaxy 3 just came out earlier
this year and you worked on that as well
what sequences from the third movie were
what it responsible for mostly in the
third act once again you guys in the
third acts of movies simply Within game
too yeah no it's it's kind of our bread
and butter
and there's so much going on here
and the wide-angle lens too oh man that
that linear field of view oh that's so
cool
[Music]
through the hole man wow I came up with
that idea look at that I got the biggest
reaction so far this is like a
choreography Mega challenge I mean
there's so much going on obviously we're
seeing some real actors here we got real
Chris Pratt real uh what do you think I
mean fair fair she's an amazing actress
but I don't think she can do that yeah
oh my gosh but you're still shooting on
set you're still shooting with real
actors and real stunt people and having
to you know reconcile the camera move
through all of that while still
maintaining the fact that it doesn't cut
and of course then you have all of the
CG creatures and all of the effects
going on this is nuts it's almost over
I hope it's not this is amazing
the gut simulation also tentacles
tentacles are not easy I hear it's just
we have clinical weeks I think you're
the first person to ever just be so
casual about tentacles it's
a digital lot oh sorry
I'm not wearing the right shirt today
oh so much to unpack in just this one
dude it's remarkable obviously a lot of
stunt choreography going on here the
shooting Team Stefan ceretti is the VFX
supervisor for Marvel who oversaw this
film he has you know worked with all
those various teams to figure out how
they're going to shoot it spoiler alert
this is not one shot I figured as much
yeah it never is right it's actually 18
shots 18. okay shot over the course of
three days something this complex as
this I look at this and I imagine if the
creative comes in I just go no thank you
how on Earth as a director you know
James on set doing what he's doing and
you in a supervisory role in any
production can you wrap your mind around
this on set shooting 18 different shots
that link perfectly like this is there
any sort of tether to the virtual in the
monitors that they're seeing for timing
or anything at all once again I wasn't
on set for this but I would assume they
had a video split so that they could do
a mix between two plates so sort of see
if they were lining up there's a
breakdown of her going up under his
shoulders because it's actually two
stunts so she's rigged for one stunt and
when
so that they can rake him to flip oh
crazy okay that's a crazy match cut then
and the best part is that the camera is
about a meter in a different position
and 20 degrees off axis on the cut so
they're Digi doubles in the final
version oh well okay you know you do a
lot of choreography the choreography is
continuous all the way to the end and
then you're figuring out where the best
places to cut are I see one of those
beats was the beat where you're going
from an action and you're pushing the
quill as he starts to do his hallway
fight and we're trying to figure out
what we can do there and it's like do we
have a crustacean step in the frame
that's a you know you could do your
cliche thing where you have a crustacean
get a hole blown through them and the
camera flies to the hole and that's what
ended up making in the movie that's but
like I mean but that's such a great
example of like you have a problem the
camera's here and it needs to be over
there and you want to animate it there
it's all built in but there's not really
anything happening in the meantime so
you come up with something that happens
in the meantime yeah and in a weird way
it's another example of creativity
thriving in a box where it's like we
have this problem we need something and
this unique idea comes up that for us
watching it you know it's like well one
of the biggest most impactful parts of
the entire thing and it wasn't in the
original concept so it's pretty cool it
could be born out of that this is the
fun thing about just surrounding
yourself by talented people you know
like animation is adding so much to the
shot Mike and his team are just
constantly in there playing with ideas
they're constantly ironing out Kinks
they're making the camera work when the
camera doesn't want to work across the
cut they're figuring out how to recover
the time make the action interesting
like to motivate that that you know we
have that crustacean going with the
sword blade right there's all sorts of
fun things here that you know somebody
somewhere came up with an idea hey how's
it going I'm Griffin I make all the
thumbnails here at Corridor so if you
clicked on this video you know good job
me today I want to talk to you about
this video's sponsor better help
betterhelp is an online therapy resource
which I've been using for almost a year
now when I first started using it I was
going through some tough times that I
really needed someone to talk to and
getting started looking for a therapist
can be so overwhelming but better help
was as simple as downloading the app
filling out a few questions and being
matched with a therapist for me with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 30 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues and you can choose how
to communicate with your therapist
however you feel comfortable whether
it's through video audio call or text
message personally I like the video call
because for me connecting with someone
face to face is the best way but that
might be different for you or for anyone
else so you get to choose I not only
received help for what I was going
through at that time but have since been
able to grow in new ways and learn new
things that I probably wouldn't have if
I had just stopped once I was out of the
fire and gone back to life as usual so
if you've been thinking about going to
therapy and are interested in getting
professional high quality Care all
online go over to betterhelp.com
Corridor crew and get 10 off your first
month you can also find the link down in
the description all right let's get back
to react
25 years ago they made you from me so
you worked on a project called jamini
man
and uh this is a this is a really cool
I had to it rolls off the tongue man I
can't blame you I was Gemini okay
because I actually didn't forget for a
second
what is it
so I think it's important to note that
Gemini man was a very unique film in how
it was shot in the format it was
released in it was not only 3D but it
was high frame rate as well shot and
delivered at 120. 120 frames per second
most TVs monitors don't even display
that high of a frame rate the challenge
with the 120 because it was also native
stereo so you know once again we had two
cameras so everything has to be tracked
twice everything has to be rotoed twice
and Roto twice at 120 frames a second 4K
it just means that you can do just
amazing things with action this shot is
just absolutely insane
I love those types of shots where it's
like a fairly wide angle going down a
narrow quarter because you get all that
intense motion going by but there's a
lot going on here for instance what's
real well we're replacing Will's head
throughout the entire scene there's a
palm tree that wipes by and now we're
full mostly digital it's not fully
digital if you feel close enough you can
see it just a little pop but this is all
digital now I did not see it pop at all
so even that's digital whoa wait that's
a digital dude wait that's amazing we
had him do it but he couldn't drive the
bike up to the point so we would have to
do some kind of really elaborate
transition from a stunt guy on a bike to
Will Smith so once you're there the
transition is almost harder than just
carrying an awnaw to the end of the shot
yeah how crazy that we're there
technologically because you have to
match every drop of sweat every more on
the face because you're at 4K 120 too
right there's no there's no there's no
hiding there's no hiding at all
obviously there's a young Will Smith in
this movie and that kind of like is the
big face of the effects in my mind but
this is a subtlety that I didn't realize
gosh that's crazy to me man it's so good
no you
made a decision so this sequence here
we're looking at a young Will Smith but
it's being performed by the is it okay
to say old Will Smith the current age
Will Smith
yes that's how I will phrase it when we
started the movie I said hey look you
know casting wool is an excellent choice
he's an amazing actor the downside that
we had on all this was that he has aged
incredibly well so we were finding it
hard to make him look young enough just
to age him up to age him down he's like
what like you know like just leave the
gray hair in his hair you know don't
don't touch anything up like the
quickest way to tell that we were wrong
here is Aang would say I totally believe
that that's a real person on screen it
just looks like Will Smith's very
similar cousin you know you would just
be that one percent off or that tenth of
a percent and yeah the thing that was so
surreal about it it was real easy to get
to Will Smith in a frame but any time
any part of his face moves if it doesn't
move exactly like you're used to seeing
then it just it'll wreck the entire shot
also the poorest stretch ah stretchy
pores the looked up supervisor on the
show came to me and said hey Art has an
idea we're making the pores really cool
and we're like well how much
ironically though it is the poor man's
approach
God dang it yo
[Laughter]
can we start over oh I'm sweating now
we're all done wow wow so you draw the
lines on the face these are called flow
Maps the direction of the curve is
important because that defines the
direction of flow that's what those are
yeah the arrows have a flow Direction
then what we do is we just grow lots of
connections we basically you can see the
dark blue dots there are very little
stochastically scattered points for the
the corners of the pores okay and then
there's a system that connects the dots
in such a way that we actually can get
the proper poor shapes out of it oh it's
remarkable man so that's actually not
blood flow that's melanin density
melanin density so melanin is one of the
you know people's faces are made up of
different pigments um the red comes from
the blood the white I guess is just what
tissue is then one of the things that
happens is since it's a structure inside
the skin what happens is that as the
skin moves you actually can see the
coloration change so the melanin density
changes based off of how much you
stretch it man that's
so high level man guys if you are
enjoying what you're hearing we got a
lot more for you subscribe hit the Bell
icon if you want to be in the loop
what the hell man so this I remember
being like a big deal because it was
like we're used to seeing the Hulk in
big tentpole movies and now we're seeing
the Hulk effect in an entire TV show
it's like the scale difference is huge
yeah so it still has to be the same
quality of hope that he was yeah
the series was the Hulk takes his shirt
off half the time so you your muscle
models have to be really good you're
doing a lot of shot sculpting after the
fact we did play around a little bit
with you know that melon and stuff we
were talking about from Gemini we did
put a little bit into them and we tried
doing it all right all right um it
looked really weird so it's there but
it's dialed way back for her there's you
know creative problems and Technical
problems okay yeah because they want her
to be a Hulk but they also want her to
be glamorous and you know not just this
jacked ripped thing so you're trying to
find that perfect balances right you
must believe but not too muscly so you
end up going down this road of more
perfect skin more perfect like her hair
is Flawless everything about her is
Flawless and then you get to the end and
you're just like got it looks like a bad
Photoshop job in a magazine and it's
just like yes we've gone way too far you
know it's like you need to pull back you
know so you're constantly in this push
and pull with the the studio where
you're trying to advise them not to go
too far into that path because you know
eventually the pendant one's going to
swing the other way
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on what in your opinion
is the secret to recreating the spark in
the eyes of a CG model because the eyes
are always kind of the tell right or at
least have been throughout history and I
feel like we're bridging that Gap and
moving past that point what is the
secret sauce there I don't know when we
first started doing it but our eyes are
modeled very very accurately we model
the eye and the cornea properly which
means that corny is a material floating
inside the sclera it isn't just a ball
with a flat surface with a lens over the
top of it the sclera actually leans over
the cornea so the sclera can cast a
shadow onto the cornea so all that's
properly modeled quickest way to fall
apart is what I call doll eyes where you
get a black line if you look at it like
somebody's eye you can't see where the
Shelf ends and the eye starts it's this
beautiful transition the seamless blur
into the bottom of the eye if you have a
little bit of a dark line there it makes
it look like the eye is a glass ball
sitting inside of a latex thing whereas
it's actually tissue with fluids and the
tissue gets really translucent right as
it meets the eye so we do all that kind
of you know all that kind of detail it's
so interesting because yeah it feels
like I mean throughout visual effects
history it's always been what shortcuts
can we get to give the effect of this
thing that that we can handle
computationally and it feels like from
everything I'm hearing you know you're
talking with Gemini and the poor
stretching you're talking about the new
facial animation tools that are looking
at the muscle relationships the eye work
here it's all just computers are finally
getting us real in a way like we're
doing it the real way in a way but once
again you can never
compliment the artist enough yeah right
yeah because the computer doesn't come
up with the idea yeah oh sorry I just
mean in terms of no yeah yeah yeah I'm
just saying that you know for everything
you you mentioned there was somebody who
sat there and just went why does it look
wrong yeah what am I doing wrong what
you know what what more do I need to
consider to get this to actually shape
upright yeah I mean was She-Hulk a fun
project oh it's a great project for the
most part everybody likes doing what
they do yeah so when you work in this
industry you're surrounded by
like-minded people you're surrounded by
people who want to create a great
looking image and who try to stay away
from the harsh reality of time and money
as much as possible everybody you know
production everybody wants to try to
just make the best little game image so
you know it's it's a lot of fun guys
there's so much knowledge being shared
on this couch if it's not enough for you
we have an Extended Cut of this react on
the website Corridor digital.com and you
also get the videos a day early so no
more waiting Christmas on the 24th
sounds good huh
your mission is to destroy every tracer
of something known only as a project
starfish so the suicide squad came out a
couple years ago but one of the key
characters in that movie is The
Peacemaker starfish it's a slang term
for a butthole if there's any connection
and he ended up getting his whole show
on HBO and there's a whole bunch of
different characters but one of the
characters in that show
is an eagle and Eagles can't act
and that's one good looking bird James's
idea was that this is his sidekick this
is his sort of his comic relief which is
you know I mean you're talking about
layers on layers right you know it's
like because John Cena's character is so
humorous yeah so it's not like you're
begging for uh comic relief the
animations are fantastic once again my
cousins wait your cousin did this
Michael cousins
oh that one got me good
oh there's actually footage of a bird
hugging a human which we use for all
this oh that's great I've been hit in
the face by bald eagle before what it's
on camera yeah
not
graceful bird we could have used that
so we're obviously have a good tight
match move for all of John Cena so that
we can cash Shadows back on was it hard
making John Cena visible
[Music]
you can't see can't see me dog
so that's some effort there uh I have no
standards anymore do you find that
feathers are much more difficult than
dealing with hair for example God yeah
the thing you have to remember is that
feathers are made of hair there's the
rackus which is the spine down the
feather and then there are hairs that
come off the rackets called barbs yeah
yeah so sorry this is cut like I knew
this but I didn't comprehend this you're
totally right feathers are just hairy
sticks so but these are all rendered
that way like we don't render feathers
as textured surfaces so we actually
build up the rackets and then have all
the barbs come off it so each feather is
a few hundred hairs but then that's not
the hard part you get into a situation
where feathers or structured that they
lay on top of each other so as the
surface deforms they have to slide
across each other but it becomes a
chicken the egg problem where how do you
get them all into a rest State that's
valid because you can't have you know
once again just like the groom you can't
have them in a position it's stuck
they'll get stuck out they'll start to
flip all over the place you know so
you're constantly going through and sort
of it's basically from the tail of the
bird all the way up to the nose you
start laying them back down and then you
can simulate it and then feathers aren't
just infinitely thin they do have depth
the best way to understand that is the
neck and the eagle doesn't have a neck
this thick it has a little bitty pencil
neck but all the feathers sort of draped
out around it so you have to figure out
how to create the extra volume but also
still maintain all those non-collisions
because again you guys approaches do it
the right way do it the real way and
this just comes down to putting together
a task force for lack of a better way to
describe it of guys who are going to
model the feathers guys that's going to
simulate the feathers guys who are going
to animate the bird and make sure that
everybody has what they need to be able
to pass off to the next guy in a
somewhat stable way guys we've been
doing this show
episodes but there are still so many
more visual effects shots we need to see
so leave a comment down below letting us
know what you'd like us to take a look
at guy thank you so much for joining us
on the couch today that was a bunch of
wisdom you threw down for us today and I
really enjoyed all of it is there
anywhere our audience can appreciate
more of what you do uh well you can
always go to our website
whatfx.co.nz we have a YouTube channel
where we show some of the making ofs
that we do yeah totally well thank you
so much guys and I'll see you next week